[Aplausos]
[Música]
cuántos de ustedes están en la
universidad oa egresado de la
universidad
super
y cuantos de los que han ingresado a la
universidad tienen su título de
provisión nacional
y si les hace sentir mejor yo tampoco lo
tengo
en mi caso particular el hecho de haber
estarían fuera y luego haber vuelta aquí
momento de hacer el trámite de título de
legalización del título en provisión
nacional me di cuenta que hacer el
trámite era tan moroso y largo que
volver a hacer la carrera otra vez
entonces cinco en su doble titulación
dos años maestría en tres años diez años
pues ya voy a salir en silla de ruedas
cuando llegamos de europa con mi esposa
que es española teníamos que hacer un
trámite en ante migración ella tenía que
hacer su residencia boliviana porque
estaba casada conmigo etcétera entonces
armados de nuestro certificado de
matrimonio en provisión nacional nos
vamos a migración y después de la cola
respectiva nos toca el funcionario
un hombre cristina
edad 26
profesión médico tiene su título en
provisión nacional señora no lo que pasa
es que como decíamos chica leche no sé
qué no señora tiene que tener su título
en provisión nacional pero es que
nosotros no se puede señora tiene que
tener su título siguiente digamos
hablando con un amigo luego nos dice no
lo que pasa es que si dice una profesión
que requiere de un título universitario
entonces les van a pedir el famoso
título en provisión nacional tienen que
decir algo que no requiera una estudios
universitarios
porque puede ser que pues yo
ama de casa no voy a hacer ama de casa
infalible vamos pero es que no entiendes
hasta mientras
bueno ama de casa nos vamos otra vez a
migración al día siguiente y nos
escogemos otro funcionario no después de
la cola respectiva lo mismo un nombre
christina edad 25 ya se había bajado un
año en un día pero es lo importante
esto es importante profesión ama de casa
señora tiene que traer tres cartas
notariadas de tres personas distintas
que no están relacionadas con la familia
que testifiquen que ustedes
efectivamente aman i khas no puedes
nos fundimos en burocracias que cansan
desgastan y dan trabajo a los ineptos
trámite para este trámite para el otro
trámite para comprar trámites para
vender trámites para regalar trámite
para tramitar
este trámite tiene un costo según el
estudio del banco interamericano de
desarrollo un estudio que por cierto se
llama el fin del trámite eterno dice que
en bolivia aproximadamente 130 mil
personas al año realizan su trámite de
afiliación a la caja nacional de seguro
de salud a 130 mil personas es un
trámite sencillo tiene sin cinco
requisitos
12 pasos requiere de 13 viajes
individuales del usuario para hacer para
completar el trámite y el absurdo de 35
horas en total
si le ponemos es un poquito de precio
resulta que más o menos sale 86 por
ciento de un salario mínimo nacional se
dan cuenta nos hundimos en problemas en
procesos y en cosas sin sentido y no
estamos prestando atención a los
problemas realmente importantes que se
nos vienen encima o que ya los tenemos
encima
como que por problemas de tráfico de
contaminación el problema del agua
el problema de la deforestación de la
amazonía el problema de la educación el
mismo problema político que estamos
viviendo ahorita esas cosas no estamos
haciendo nada por ver solos
y creo que una gran parte del problema
es que somos demasiado conformistas y
poco innovadores
bolivia ocupa el país el país bolivia
ocupa el lugar 106 de 130 países a nivel
mundial en innovación según el índice
global de innovación publicado para la
universidad de berkeley cada año
estamos en la cola
y encima nuestro vecino chile ocupa el
primer lugar de innovación en
latinoamérica y nosotros ocupamos el
último dígame usted es que tiene chile
que no tengamos nosotros no no medir
mejor
creo que
parte del problema que tenemos por un
lado es cultural la viveza criolla la
cultura de la copia en el colegio
copiamos las tareas copiamos los
exámenes en la universidad copiamos los
trabajos copiamos las tesis copiamos la
música copiamos las películas copiados
los programas copiamos la propiedad
intelectual y más adelante cuando un
negocio es exitoso lo copiamos y encima
lo ponemos a su lado y terminamos con el
absurdo de la calle de las ferreterías
la calle de las pinturerías la calle de
los tornillos la calle de los cafés la
calle de los repuestos de auto la calle
de la venta de automóviles ya calle de
la ciudad venta de perros
cómo podemos ser innovadores si todos
los copiamos
pero yo me preguntaba un poco que hace
que nos ponga en este según este índice
global de innovación tan abajo en
latinoamérica y que caracteriza otros
países que los ponen más arriba para eso
tenemos que entender cómo se calcula
este índice global de innovación
este índice global de innovación es un
número que se le asigna a cada país y
luego se pone un ranking y ese ranking
nos dice más o menos en qué lugar está
resulta que este índice en realidad es
el promedio de varios otros subíndices
cada uno de estos suministros de ahí
representa una distinta vertical y cada
una de estas verticales se mide en base
a una serie de indicadores que son
fácilmente calculable por ejemplo para
que se haga una idea capital una de
investigación para calcular este
subíndice se usa un indicador que es
cuántas publicaciones científicas ha
hecho el país en el año
por otro lado creatividad uno de los
indicadores es cuántos vídeos de youtube
ha subido el país en el año se dan
cuenta ok entonces yo decía tiene que
haber algo distinto dentro de estos
indicadores que nos diferencia de otros
países en latinoamérica y efectivamente
así es medio el trabajo de ir a graficar
cada uno de estos subíndices y ver dónde
nos colocábamos con respecto a nuestros
vecinos
aquí hay dos infraestructura y captar
una investigación si se fijan más o
menos vemos los países más innovadores
bien arriba suiza por ejemplo y luego
vemos que hay una especie de
países latinoamericanos que están en un
rango en una franja latinoamericana más
o menos y ahí bolivia está medio que
batiéndose con nosotros fíjense este
otro otros dos subíndices y más o menos
y aquí hay otro
casi todos tienen una similitud estamos
dentro de la dentro de la media de todos
todos excepto uno que es el marco
institucional en el marco institucional
que es básicamente el apoyo que da el
gobierno a las empresas a las industrias
para que eventualmente éstas puedan
tener un cierto impacto en la innovación
estamos en la cola
qué tiene que ver el trámite con la
innovación se preguntarán ustedes tiene
mucho que ver pues según este mismo
estudio que les decía de el banco
interamericano de desarrollo ellos han
hecho
cálculo de cuánto tiempo le tarda un
ciudadano de apie realizar un trámite en
su país
y resulta que
los países
resulta que los países más innovadores
tienen una duración de trámite bien bajo
chile por ejemplo dos horas para hacer
un trámite argentina 48 y nosotros en el
primer lugar o en el último según lo vea
con 11 horas para hacer el mismo trámite
parecería que hay
una relación inversamente proporcional
entre la longitud del trámite y con
innovadores un país
pero el trámite no lo es todo el marco
institucional abarca muchas más cosas y
para darles un ejemplo les voy a hablar
un poco de mi trabajo en el área de
desarrollo de software y son más de 15
años que estoy en él
en las trincheras por decirlo en estos
15 años
la industria de desarrollo de software
ha crecido a pasos gigantescos para que
se haga una idea de 6 personas que
éramos en ese entonces hemos crecido a
más de 600 ingenieros y más de 800
empleados en la empresa
si ese número les parece impresionante
imagínense ustedes que el número de
empresas de software ha crecido más de
200 veces efectivamente en cochabamba
solamente hay más de 200 empresas del
software que están haciendo tecnología
de punta fabricando
y propiedad intelectual con ingenieros
de primer nivel que se están creando con
ingenieros de américa del norte con
ingenieros de europa primer nivel y
produciendo propiedad intelectual todo
el tiempo
lamentablemente la historia se repite
cuando yo era cuando estaba en colegio a
ese tiempo no se veía hace tiempo
mi profesor de sociales me decían el
estaño que sacamos de las minas lo
exportamos a los países del norte y
europa y estos no los devuelven en forma
de producto acabado muchas veces su
precio original en forma de automóviles
televisores teléfonos usted sea
pasan los años muchos años y otra vez el
mismo el mismo cuento los chinos se
están llevando el litio del salar para
devolvernos en forma de baterías de
celulares y baterías de computadoras
personales el software es lo mismo
estamos desarrollando propiedad
intelectual
pero se está yendo afuera y nuestra
contribución al índice de innovación de
nuestro país es prácticamente cero como
podríamos imaginar si ustedes
una empresa que quiere empezar a
funcionar en nuestro país tiene que
hacer un trámite espantoso y seguir la
desgracia tremenda para crear la empresa
y una vez creada tiene que lidiar
compuestos tiene que lidiar con dobles
aguinaldos tiene que lidiar con leyes
laborales absurdas encima de nuestro
rubro en particular tiene que líder con
la ley de exportación de software
ridícula tenemos que mandar el software
en cede al cliente final para que
justifique el ingreso de divisas
mientras que en otros países se hace de
forma electrónica en todos los países de
forma lista peor todavía
las empresas de software tienen su valor
en su propiedad intelectual
netflix facebook no tiene el valor que
tienen por la infraestructura tiene el
valor que tiene por su propiedad
intelectual
lamentablemente en bolivia no se puede
registrar la propiedad intelectual como
patrimonio de la empresa en esas
condiciones no sabemos no les parece a
ustedes que las empresas encontrarían un
justificativo para irse a trabajar en
otros lugares que les dan un techo más
acogedor o finalmente trabajar
simplemente en lo informal
según un estudio del banco y del fondo
monetario internacional
qué estudiado qué porcentaje del
producto interno bruto de un país es o
qué porcentaje del mercado y de la
economía informal contribuye al producto
interno bruto de un país estos son los
resultados
en suiza por ejemplo 7% de su producto
interno bruto es resultado de la
economía informal colombia un 33 por
ciento y bolivia 66 por ciento de
nuestro producto interno bruto el
resultado de la economía informal
se dan cuenta
estamos mal
qué tenemos que hacer sabemos porque
estamos mal pero qué es lo que tenemos
que hacer para dejar de estar ahí creo
que son tres cosas fundamentales la
primera creo que tenemos que empezar a
hacer ciudadanos de verdad buenos
ciudadanos
a pagar impuestos a cumplir las leyes
fíjese que estamos aquí donde estamos
porque justamente hemos abusado del
sistema el udi hemos impuesto
seguiríamos las leyes me pasó el rojo
porque tenemos que empezar a hacer las
cosas bien segundo claro está
tenemos que empezar a apoyar lo nuestro
comprar lo nacional por un lado pero
apoyar lo nuestro también no es sólo
comprar lo nacional sino que cuando
vamos a comprar lo importado que no sea
de contrabando
exijamos factura
y finalmente el tercer y tal vez punto
más importante es que dejemos de ser
espectadores y empecemos a ser actores
si no estamos felices con impuestos
vayamos a trabajar impuestos si no
estamos felices con los abogados seamos
abogados si no estamos felices con los
políticos seamos políticos empecemos a
ser parte de la solución y dejemos de
ser parte del problema
creo que tenemos un arduo trabajo por
delante y hoy ha hecho un poquito de lo
mío ahora les toca a ustedes seguirlo
haciendo que tienen más tiempo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]